hello everyone and welcome to some more
rapid action on leeches you guys
requested uh some more rapid games says
uh okay uh they're not as uh you know
played on the level of the players that
usually show but it's easier to follow
and you guys can maybe learn a little
bit more from them so I will continue
playing them uh so let's check it out
and it also helps me uh to at least uh
try and play uh you know actual moves on
a daily basis
um for example next next Sunday I have a
a classical game in my Croatian chess
league so it will be nice you know to
have a few games played uh before that
so our opponent this game is from India
rocket Rockstar 2018 and he opens with
E4 uh and we're again gonna go for the
Scandinavian defense so he takes uh and
we're gonna take uh so let's uh let's
see let's see what he does
all right so pretty standard stuff and
this is why I always recommend this
queen to d67 because everyone pretty
much always plays
um standard moves against it we're gonna
go A6 simply to end of the night and uh
you know the standard Knight to F6 and
then we're gonna decide what to do with
the light Square Bishop okay so G3 is
um fairly standard he can play Bishop to
F4 to attack Our Queen and here the game
can become really really interesting
yeah so he does it now uh sometimes okay
I've never actually tried this in in uh
wrap it in in bullet I will go Queen to
be for uh without thinking uh because it
uh creates a very uh unique experience
of a game but as this is the first time
I'm trying it in Rapid I'm also going to
try it I'm gonna give up the C7 Pawn uh
pretending I'm interested in the B2 Pawn
I'm really not interested in the B2 pawn
and you should never capture it there
are some lines where you could capture
that this is um pretty sure this is not
one of them uh so we'll see what he
decides on the on the C7 uh Pawn uh I
mean you should definitely take it uh
but he doesn't Okay so he he trusts my
judgment uh you should never trust in
someone's judgment interests
um
well maybe I'm wrong maybe maybe it's
actually better not to take the pawn
and now he will go after my queen with
moves like A3 and B4
uh or he will simply decide that maybe
it's too dangerous to keep this Pawn on
D4 as we do have a lot of pressure on it
all right so this is another thing that
uh we should we should learn
uh how to properly go about this uh uh
Bishop F4 line
yeah but there are there are so many
nuances uh when playing this line uh
sometimes this query is good for for
your piece sometimes it's not so it's
really uh okay so uh now I'm pretty sure
that this cannot be played uh it looks
really weird
like I have no idea what to make of this
uh okay so we have time it's a rapid
game uh not not uh
I mean
yeah okay I'm I would spend more time
but I don't see what his plan is
I really don't
like Bishop captures Knight captures and
maybe C3 is that the plan
huh
I mean I would be
I would be amazed if this actually works
can't can't possibly be be true
but on the other hand when I play with
white against this line I I yeah he he
does go for C3 wow so what am I missing
here he's gonna take I'm gonna take
uh
yeah okay
oh
yeah really nice really nice
I mean it's not spectacular or anything
I'm just uh I'm just probably gonna win
a pawn and that's it uh with uh him
being a little bit ahead in development
uh but I I don't think like it's it's
enough for white
so we'll see okay
yeah he takes with the bishop takes with
the bishop and this is a
yeah so same thing every game pretty
much okay
we have anything better no we don't
yeah okay we'll take
we'll take it move our Queen and prepare
Pawn to E5 so
sounds like a plan
yeah probably go with some like H A4 and
B4 because now he has to go for the
attack he does have nasty pressure here
against my king uh but you've seen in
the previous video that I've played this
line of the Scandinavian white always
has a nasty pressure on your king
yeah and again sorry sorry if my voice
sounds weird uh like I said in the
previous video uh uh yeah my daughter
you know always brings something from
the kindergarten and uh it always
attacks the voice it's the incredible
stuff oh G4 even wow
okay I'm having a harder and harder time
believing that uh
this can be played
right he's gonna go G5 as well probably
[Music]
yeah well E5 is super scary here
like even if he plays yeah okay so he's
gonna attack the pawn
makes sense
um
all right so now it's time to hmm
yeah okay he definitely Justified uh
being down a pawn
but we're used to that not a big deal
yeah I don't want to over push it I
don't want to over push
like I did in the previous game where
you know B4 B4 is coming probably or or
you know Rook Rook to D1 but
these are all
yeah before of course
and and B5 next
huh
let's play G5
this positioning of the of the king
queen and pawn doesn't really look all
that impressive
and if he goes here then I have F6 and
then I have E5 uh everything with Tempo
so that doesn't work probably he will
not accept the challenge he'll just move
back with the bishop but then I'm very
happy
uh uh to get re okay he does he does
accept it very nice
very nice
okay let's go here
yeah B5 uh probably we will ignore that
yeah no I'm not uh saying that you know
he he got a very nice position for his
uh sacrificed Pawn
uh yeah maybe this is uh maybe you
should
huh
if G5 were just gonna attack it further
so
I'm hoping he's gonna start weakening
his uh King side instead of going uh for
a counter attack yeah okay so we're
gonna further attack it
now B5 has to land if B5 doesn't land
now okay so he will
even do that
okay
let's take once
if the bishop takes uh yeah Bishop takes
is probably best no he takes with the
pawn
huh
I don't think this is very good but okay
hmm
yeah this is a nice kind of threatening
Checkmate but then he will play F3 and
we don't really have a
good reply F3
so
so where is the the killer move
we go here
with some E5 action yeah now B5 has to
be played
uh like I said we're gonna ignore this
move because it's not really all that
impressive
we're just gonna hide our Queen here
we're gonna hide our Queen here
and keep an eye on the C7 Pawn we don't
want to blunder that yeah
we're not touching this uh I'd much
rather him he have uh the the open B
file than the open a file
hmm
alright so it's a pretty wild position
but uh you know if you played the queen
D6 Scandinavian you will always have a
pretty wild position
so now I'm even considering Queen
captures uh because this is no longer an
option due to a rook captures on G5
and E5 is coming E5 will hurt a lot if
he doesn't stop it
so some Rook move I'm pretty sure he has
to play it
but then Rook D3 also becomes an option
uh
really crazy A crazy position yeah I
know he goes for this okay
now if I'm not getting checkmated this
should be very very good for me this
should be very good for me if I'm not
getting checkmated
huh
alright so how do we do this so if I
play E5 first
which is of course very interesting he
will just capture I can capture with the
King uh then he can capture here with
checks so that's not an option our King
has to remain um on a light Square
now we play E5
now we play five
uh there's also some checkmating
potential for him even if he sacrifices
my queen like I could very easily
imagine uh like a bishop Rook combo
check mating my king here
uh but he stops it uh or rather I no
longer have to worry about it
um oh Queen has a check very nice say if
I open up the light score diagonal he
has a check
okay
very resourceful very resourceful
so we're gonna
attack The Rook first
yeah that's very sneaky of him
or no this check we move the king he
takes the bishop I take the bishop
[Music]
no Queen is actually better here
defending the bishop
yeah the queen check uh if here
it's not all that useful
yeah okay
not all that useful maybe if he doesn't
see that my queen is uh defending my
Bishop I didn't see it at first
so it is possible that he misses it as
well
uh or does he want some Queen check
followed by Queen here and then
sacrifice the queen for mate as his
Bishop is controlling this I don't think
he has time for something like that but
you know we should uh
we shouldn't uh
not see stuff like that
okay he goes for it we're gonna go
uh King the
not the best square like I said
maybe he doesn't see it
that'd be that'd be a sad way for him to
lose
uh but now he has to do something and
once my Rook enters the game uh it's
gonna be very hard for him he can't go
here he has to go
somewhere here or here I can easily
shift my queen here
yeah it's not going to be easy
yeah this game I feel like uh the engine
bar was going crazy like he's winning
I'm winning he's winning I'm winning or
maybe he was winning for the entire game
I don't know
but the both of us are really spending a
lot of time we're not just you know
playing a 10 minute game to to get it
over with in five five minutes
yeah well if you haven't seen my
previous video uh brilliant brilliant
game between uh uh Bulgaria's number one
below
uh like that that really is uh quite a
game do check it out
yeah and uh yeah I've sort of already
imagined that I've won this game but
that that's a silly thing to do so I
should really look for
any ideas my opponent could have
yeah maybe this was his plan but then he
realized that the queen is defending the
version is like oh man
why why you do this
hmm
oh
yeah that's a great move sacrifice the
bishop for the for the past Pawn
I like it
I like it a lot how it takes
or he takes with the pawn even better
so do I want to take the bishop that's
the question or do I do I give check
first
now check first is better
check first is better
we might not even have to take the the
bishop
yeah because now if he goes here okay so
he goes here and if I threaten Checkmate
he will probably play this uh is there
any other move he can do
we need you to know I'm pretty sure this
is game rookie two I don't have to take
the bishop I have two more minutes so
you know
I don't have to rush it
I could also just play Rook H1 with Rook
captures here or like what do I prefer
that's the real question
this kind of requires me to calculate a
bit more and I don't see a move for him
after
Rook here
do I see a move for him yeah if I play a
rook here he can play Queen here I
capture he moves the king behind the
queen I tried to take the bishop and of
course it's winning Okay so
yeah it's a pretty good time to resign
unless he he just doesn't feel like
calculating he's going to play Queen to
G2 instantly
but it doesn't uh do all that much
Okay so
what is this he's still gonna try and
play this
okay
uh we're even
gonna threaten Checkmate since he's not
resigning
so let's be cheeky about it
he's gonna take now
maybe he tries to flag me
maybe he doesn't know I've played 50 000
bullet games who knows
okay so Checkmate all right that was a
that was a very nice game and luckily my
voice survived and yeah some some of you
asked why do I get so many points for a
win is because I haven't uh played 20
rating games uh since I have my leeches
account as I've never played rapid and
uh for the like the first 20 games you
have to you know figure out what your
rating is and then you gain points uh
that that's why you get so many points
for a win but if I lost I would also
lose like 100 points so uh you know it
will place you uh where you belong you
know in your tier uh so yeah uh let's uh
check it out let's analyze this a little
bit because I'm sure this was uh well
this was a disaster of a game so
especially with that uh yeah okay uh up
until this point okay so here already
there are some moves uh that can be
played better sorry about that let me
just
get rid of this alright so
uh Bishop therefore yeah Queen before
already says it's winning for for white
like I said but you have to play A3 and
but uh for some reason no one plays it
and that's um you know uh where I
actually go for Queen to B4 because no
one plays it because you can't capture
on B2 you're just gonna lose the game
terribly so he played Bishop to D3 and
now my position is just uh better Bishop
to G4 but this was just a one-time thing
I'm not like if I'm doing a video I'm
not gonna play this uh the silly Queen
to be for line anymore uh you know not
to trick you guys uh Bishop to B3 okay
uh and now we're completely winning uh
but it says okay Knight captures on D4
should be played right away after
castles uh and this move yeah it's just
uh Knight captures oh no Rook captures
was better ah okay root captures was
better
Rook captures uh simply because
yeah
makes sense yeah I don't know why I
played Knight captures this was a
a really funny few moves at the start of
the game so basically after all of this
we now have a completely equal game yeah
uh I'm up upon and he's up in
development wow yeah okay this is fine
this is fine yeah he he overdid it with
the push of the G Pawn uh Queen C6 only
movie I played that well uh G5 not
recommended but the engine doesn't hate
it so I'm I'm very happy with that uh
Rook here Bishop here okay F5 says F5 is
a mistake but I mean what are you gonna
do G5 H6 yeah H4 not the best yeah he he
should have just gone four
a rook trade on the D file captures
characters captures now Rook Hade sort
of best yeah I thought about that move
but I didn't like it after this F3 idea
uh I don't know what uh what the engine
has in mind there and now if F3 which is
Bishop G7 okay
sure sure yeah just you know 10 like uh
your playing positional chest okay uh
Bishop goes here okay he attacked my
Pawn this is still pretty equal and now
this is the the losing move obviously
uh Rook to D1 I trade and go E5 yeah
okay we we spotted that nicely onto F4
yeah we spotted that nicely okay and now
after captures and captures uh there's
just no wind here uh Rook to g80i even
faster even faster uh with the with the
thread of Checkmate here but this is
also fine yeah
uh so you know aside from aside from
basically playing a terrible opening uh
which is my uh weakest suit you know uh
I I find some moves in the in the middle
game uh you know I don't mind playing
the end game but my openings are just
Dreadful
uh so yeah okay uh
definitely yeah never never go for Queen
to B4 again even if you you know uh
survive it uh you will uh you don't play
it uh so yeah this line all together so
we're gonna have to figure out how to
yeah Bishop to G4 right away and don't
play Silly moves and you know just
continue playing the game if you already
want to play this line uh so yeah that's
the game I hope you guys enjoyed it
we'll we'll see what happens in the next
one we are all ready okay with this 2141
plus we're already over 2200 so we'll
see uh I I always set my opponents to be
uh higher rated than me uh so we will
get someone between 20 200 and 2700
should be very a very exciting game and
hopefully I will play some better chess
uh so yeah thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day and if you haven't do check out the
game between uh meowulu and uh
really a really a wild game uh thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day